welcome cyber security Enthusiast today
we are diving deep into the intricate
world of malware analysis tools in the
ever evolving landscape of digital
threats understanding the tools at our
disposal is crucial for safeguarding our
systems whether you are a seasoned cyber
security professional or just beginning
your journey into the world of malware
analysis this video is a gateway to the
essential tools that that Empower us to
dissect understand and combat malicious
software so buckle up as we explore the
Arsenal of malware analysis tools and
learn how these digital detectives work
to keep our digital spaces secure if you
want to upskill yourself master cyber
security skills and learn your dream job
or grow in your career then you must
explore simply learns cohort of various
cyber Security Programs simply learn
offers various certification and
postgraduation certifications in
collaboration with some of the world's
leading universities like MIT it kpur EC
Council and many more through our
courses you will gain knowledge and work
ready expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others and that's not all
you also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in Top Tire
product and security companies and
academicians from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into a cyber
security role as a fresher or move on to
a higher paying job and profile if you
are passionate about making your career
in this field then make sure to check
out the link in the pin comment and
description box to find a cyber security
program that fits your experience and
areas of interest and with that we'll
start with the malware analysis tools
and the first on the list is p studio so
P studio is efficient tool for
preliminary analysis of Windows
executables it ALS also facilitates
quick extraction of suspicious artifacts
and if we talk about hashes and virus
total detections it provides malare
hashes and virus total detections upon
loading a binary and it unveils a list
of strings with considerations for
packed samples and if we talk about the
entropy analysis for packed Malo it
measures the entropy level to determine
if the malware is packed and higher
entropy indicates a greater likelihood
of packing
obscuring true functionality and talking
about insightful import stab import stab
reveals functionality imported by the
malware and the useful for predicting
potential malware Behavior based on
imported apis so this was about the P
studio tool and the second on the list
is process hacker so process hacker
offers a comprehensive view of running
processes on a device and it is
essential for observing new process
creation and identify ifying evasion
tactics and talking about memory
inspection for malware analysis it
allows inspection of process memory for
Strings post malare detonation and it
extracts valuable information such as IP
addresses domains and user agents and
talking about identification of
malicious activities it detects malware
attempts to hide by coping and renaming
itself and it provides a clear depiction
of how malware conceals its presence on
disk and then we have realtime process
monitoring so this tool enables realtime
monitoring of processes aiding in the
identification of malicious activities
and patterns so this was about the
second tool process hecher and moving on
to the third tool that is process
Monitor and procmon like it's a short
form or acronym for process monitor so
it's a robust Microsoft tool that
records realtime file system activity
including process creations and registry
changes and it is vital for
complimenting process hacker it captures
processes swiftly created and terminated
allowing for in-depth analysis and
talking about its functionality it
offers pre-build filters and a process
Tre facilitating rapid identification of
created processes execution locations
and parent or child dependencies and the
particular advantages in analyzing
malicious documents revealing hidden
power processes and encoded commands and
if we talk about the use cases emotet
that is ideal for dissecting attacks
like emotet where malicious Word
documents execute macros leading to C2
infrastructure communication and payload
downloads and it captures the entire
sequence from opening the word document
to the execution of concealed processes
and if we talk about the challenge the
event volume so it records over 1 lakh
events in seconds or 100,000 thousand
events in seconds posing a challenge to
analyst and it filters mitigate risk but
potential event misses are addressed by
exporting data to the next tool and if
we talk about the export capability it
enables data export as a CSV ensuring
seamless integration with subsequent
analysis tools and the next on the list
is proc do this is the fourth malare
analysis tools and talking about the
functionality So Pro do complement Pro
mode automating the creation of
graphical representations from captured
data and it streamlines analysis by
generating visual diagrams from uploaded
proon CSV files and talking about
Simplicity navigation so it eliminates
the need for creating complex filters
and sifting through vast event logs and
it provides a userfriendly visual
representation of malware activity and
integration with wire shock it enhances
proon data by allowing the ingestion of
wire shock p PC AP files providing a
more comprehensive view of network
interactions and talking about
streamlined analysis it simplifies the
navigation of complex data sets making
it accessible to analyst without
extensive filtering expertise and
talking about the next that is efficient
enrichment it enriches proon data by
incorporating additional information
from tools like V Shar contributing to a
more detailed analysis of malware
Behavior so this was about the to Tool
now moving to the next tool that is auto
runs so Auto runs it's a Microsoft tool
that unveils all installed software set
to launch during a device startup and
the malware despite its ability to hide
needs to run and establish a persistent
mechanism for survival after a reboot
and talking about the persistent
techniques so malware achieves
persistence through techniques like
creating scheduled task or specific run
Keys within the registry and auto runs
when running a virtual machine after
malware execution identifies and
highlights new persistent software and
the employee technique making it
invaluable for malware analysis and
talking about significance so Auto runs
AIDS in uncovering the methods malware
uses to maintain a foothold on a system
and the tools ability to detect and
showcase the Persistence of mechanisms
of newly introduced software contribute
significantly to the analysis of malware
Behavior so this was about the fifth
tool that is aor Rance and now moving to
the next tool that is Fiddler utilizing
Fiddler for malware analysis malware
frequently utilizes HTTP or https to
communicate with its command and control
servers and download additional
malicious components or exfiltrate data
so fidler's functionality as a web proxy
captures and analyzes this traffic
offering insights into the Mal's
communication patterns and we talk about
analyzing malicious documents so Fiddler
proves instrumental in analyzing
malicious documents employing macros to
download a harmful payload and in the
presented example fidler recorded a
malicious Word document attempting to
download emotet from multiple websites
providing a clear view of the domains
hardcoded into the document and talking
about domain identification for a
malware analyst fidler serves as a
powerful tool to identify domains
hardcoded in malicious documents and the
capture traffic illustrates attempts by
the malware to download from various
websites offering a comprehensive view
of the malware's propagation and
potential evasion strategies and now
coming on the seven tool and the last
tool that is V shock so V shock serves
as the primary tool for capturing and
analyzing Network traffic offering deep
packet inspection for various protocols
and layers beyond the scope of HTTP or
https traffic typically handled by web
proes like Fiddler and the tool excels
in providing a comprehensive view of
network activities allowing for the
extraction of files from packet captures
that may have been downloaded by malare
during its operation and the VRE Chuck
versatility lies in the capability to
conduct in-depth analysis across
multiple protocols making it an
essential tool for malware analyst
seeking a holistic understanding of
network interactions so this was all for
this tutorial and as we include our
exploration of malare analysis tools
remember that staying ahead in the cyber
security game requires continuous
learning and adaption these tools are
the shields in our digital armor helping
us decipher the language of malare and
fortify our defenses if you like the
session then like share and subscribe if
you have any questions then you can drop
them in the comment section below thanks
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply loarn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling what whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here